zanda a gaza ma chi è tornato un occhio
inesperto potrebbe credere che questo
tizio sia io la realtà è che no quello
che vedete un androide creato apposta
per essere preso in giro dalla propria
famiglia ragazzi ad arrestare cosa avete
fa per il portabagagli oppure raggiunge
come altra definizione a casa grazie per
potermi spiegare questo abuso di potere
però credo che sia necessario andare
indietro di qualche ora abbiamo la
possibilità comunicante averla sentita
sinistra e dirà io e il mio meraviglioso
team siamo stati invitati qualche
settimana fa dal presidente della
repubblica alla cena della repubblica
ora diciamo subito che la giornata
parole partita proprio in maniera
eccellente abbiamo la possibilità di
entrare all'interno della del quirinale
ma non ha dato la possibilità di
accedere nella zona cucina quirinale
ridotti a liquida niger
la cena di gala organizzata da ragazzi
strepitosi istituti alberghieri
buonasera allora più grossi della luce
mi porta al quirinale cortesemente siamo
arrivati finalmente dopo due ore
a questo evento ho portato con me mio
fratello enrico
perché ho bisogno di qualcuno che
reggesse la videocamera non perché lo
volessi davvero e mia cugina la vigna
che essendo un avvocato mi permette ecco
di compensare la vergogna che provo nel
portare in giro mio fratello
volete un caffè la sia parte i momenti
in cui se ne esce con frasi sicule a
caso tipo favolosa anche se 100 per
cento romana di qualcosa di bello in
questo giardino ma questo giardino è
bello
questa è una delle cucine ne abbiamo
installato e più di una li abbiamo tutti
i ragazzi della scuola alberghiera e
abbiamo sono tutti miscelati di è un
italianista nord sud e centro ovest est
domanda il motivo per cui ci troviamo
qualche siamo stati invitati dal
presidente della repubblica il giorno
prima della festa della repubblica
siamo stati invitati insieme ad altri
ragazzi per portarvi all'interno di
questo evento che farvi vedere
effettivamente una cosa che mi ha
colpito molto gli squadra che funzionano
meglio sono quelle che si allenano tanto
c assieme come ci si relaziona invece
una squadra completamente nuova
e così naturalmente anche diversa e a
livello di it a livello di percorso
risponde di studi nord sud est ovest e
tutti quanti sia il reale stato grande e
bellissima ci sono delle basi uguali per
tutti
quindi una volta che ci si incontra non
è importante che tipo di gioco fai
comunque restiamo quo cioè se parli di
salsa pomodoro è quello coesa anche che
poi inventa la luna e io ci riesco a
diventarne la mangiata con te questi
ragazzi mi ha riportato alla mente la
mia adolescenza mi ha fatto ricordare le
paure le ansie ma allo stesso tempo i
sogni e le aspettative e la voglia di
trasformare ogni cosa in una grande
opportunità per costruire il proprio
futuro
e bellissimo vedere che ancora oggi i
giovani vengono trattati come una
grandissima risorsa per il nostro
presente
siete tutti tutti quanti capolavoro
ragazzi e la strizza una cosa positiva
se sei sul palco una striscia
assolutamente perderci sento se parla
senza strizza il più delle volte della
chimica con quel
a chiudere le mani così
stiamo mangiando senza mangiare
entra nei polmoni dei sei pole ma non e
calciando direttamente allo stomaco
rapido processo che mi guardo bene ci
rendete conto
così prende invece di invitare
il di terreno questo non sapete che la
pensate io grazie di cuore
facciamo vedere un attimo come sto posto
una carrellata parecchie l'ha vista in
macchina non è il derby ho qui
[Applauso]
male ci sta pure il doriano è visto che
sto per andarmene linea da enrico
purtroppo per un impegno di lavoro non
potrò fare la cosa che più mi andava di
fare in assoluto cara incontrare il
presidente della repubblica ed è per
questo che ho deciso di passare così
d'amblé la linea a enrico e lavinia
ragazzi e so già che mi pentirò di
questa scelta
vi chiedo scusa ma non avevo veramente
altro modo per farvi vedere che cosa
succede dopo enrico si sta mangiando
anche la scatolina parole giocabilità
grazie enrico per la classe mi perdona
il presidente la prossima volta non
lascia a casa col guinzaglio
le piante queste forze ci andava dal
prendiamo bellissimi e lì per noi è un
grandissimo numerica per fermare gli
alimenti riguardante abbiamo le
competenze farlo non la risposta è no no
e poi nodo essere io che stringo la mano
dovevo essere io che in dico io che
sorrido qui felice
io che restringo le mani così con
l'allegria io che stinchi che non lo so
che cosa succede qui ma siamo ragazzi
per dire la verità permetta dalle
emozioni più grandi della mia vita
ringrazio cacciata dalla possibilità di
godere di questa cosa meravigliosa ciao